[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
willkommen rudizane ist auch dabei für
den Sport sehr gerne schönen guten Abend
und das sind die Nachrichten Themen von
heute
die G7 starten suchen eine Antwort auf
Chinas und Russlands Machtanspruch die
globalen Krisen bestimmen den Gipfel in
Hiroshima
er ist wieder dabei Syriens Diktator
Assad darf in der Arabischen Liga wieder
mitreden
und ein spannendes Bundesliga-Wochenende
beginnt nach dem vorletzten Spieltag
können Meister und Absteiger feststehen
oder auch nicht
[Musik]
vor fast 80 Jahren wurde Hiroshima von
einer amerikanischen Atombombe zerstört
heute geht vom G7 Gipfel dort die
Botschaft aus ein Atomkrieg darf niemals
geführt werden Russland wird
aufgefordert sich sofort unverzüglich
und bedingungslos aus der Ukraine
zurückzuziehen zudem soll neue
Sanktionen die russische Kriegsmaschine
aus Russland beschränken den Export von
kriegsgütern nach Russland sanktionieren
und sie wollen Strafmaßnahmen für
Staaten und Unternehmen die Russlands
Krieg unterstützen vom G7 Gipfel aus
Japan berichtet Elma Tee wissen
es gibt Orte an denen man nur still sein
kann demütig der Friedenspark von
Hiroshima ist so ein Ort gerade haben
sie im Museum die Simulation gesehen von
dem was hier 1945 geschah als sein
US-Präsident die Atombombe einsetzte um
einen Krieg zu beenden
die 70.000 Todesopfer ermahnen sie
dringend nach einem Ausweg aus dem
jetzigen Krieg zu suchen
für die Kameras sollen sie
Geschlossenheit demonstrieren gemeinsam
beschließen sie dann die Sanktionen zu
verschärfen und Schlupflöcher zu
schließen es gehe auf diesem Gipfel sagt
Japans premier kishida nur um eines
nicht Teilung und Konfrontation sondern
Kooperation
sie verhöhnen kishida als Puppe der
US-Regierung weil Japan massiv aufrüstet
glauben die Demonstranten dass sich ihr
Land von Amerika in einen Krieg mit
China drängen lässt der Gipfel will auch
eine härtere Linie gegen Peking
beschließen das ist ein Kriegsbündnis
der Unterführung von beiden
die Europäer Ringen noch um eine
gemeinsame Linie gegenüber China
immerhin bei der harten Haltung zu
Russland und der Waffenhilfe für die
Ukraine gäbe es bei allen
gipfel-teilnehmern so der Bundeskanzler
einen entschlossenen Konsens er ist auch
wichtig weil er ja auch eine Botschaft
enthält nämlich das ein fairer Frieden
nur möglich ist wenn Russland einsieht
dass es diesen Krieg beenden muss und
Truppen zurückziehen muss am Ende noch
ein kleiner Schreck Moment der Moskau
und Peking nicht Unrecht sein dürfte
dabei soll doch von hier ein Signal der
stärker ausgehen und dafür kommt eigens
am Sonntag noch der ukrainische
Präsident für das symbolträchtigste Foto
vom Gipfel
Andreas ist von Berlin nach Japan
mitgereist Andreas was ist die große
Herausforderung dieses Gipfels
die Herausforderung ist neue Wege zu
finden weil die G7 merken dass von den
bisherigen nicht alle funktionieren die
Sanktionen gegen die russische
Wirtschaft gegen die russische
Rüstungsindustrie wirken aber die
sanktionsumgehungen wirken auch und zwar
zunehmend vor allem über die Länder
Zentralasien scheinen jetzt doch
wirklich große Mengen sanktionierter
Produkte nach Russland zu gelangen die
deutsche Autoindustrie hat ihre Exporte
nach Kasachstan ver fünfach die Exporte
von Autoersatzteilen nach Kirgisistan
sind um 4.000% gestiegen und angesichts
solcher Zahlen wollte US-Präsident
beiden hier in Hiroshima am liebsten ein
generelles Exportverbot für Russland
verhängen da haben aber die anderen
sechs nicht mitgemacht es bleibt jetzt
beim Stopfen von Schlupflöchern vor
allem für kriegswichtige Industrie und
darüber will man morgen auch reden mit
Brasilien Indien und Indonesien das ist
dann einer dieser Wege die nicht sofort
erfolgt bringen wenn überhaupt
danke schön für diese Einschätzung live
aus Hiroshima Andreas
bei den G7 in Japan wird der ukrainische
Präsident noch erwartet beim Gipfel der
Arabischen Liga ist vorladimir selensky
heute überraschend erschienen für
Syriens macht aber Assad ist dieser
Gipfel im saudi-arabischen Gitter die
Rückkehr auf die große diplomatische
Bühne zur arabischen Liga gehören rund
20 Länder in Asien und Afrika 2011 war
Syriens Mitgliedschaft ausgesetzt worden
wegen des brutalen Vorgehens des
Assad-Regimes gegen die eigene
Bevölkerung jetzt ist es hat erstmals
seit zwölf Jahren wieder eingeladen mehr
von goldene atai
Premiere in Saudi-Arabien der Präsident
der Ukraine in einer Region die eher
Russland zugeneigt ist und selbst auf
Drängen des Westens vermieden hat klar
Stellung zu beziehen angesichts der
russischen Invasion silenski weiß
saudi-Arabien hat einen engen Draht zu
Moskau der Gastgeber will vermitteln
selensky will für seinen Friedensplan
werden und seine Gegner im Saal
überzeugen
leider wollen einige in der Welt und
einige hier im Saal Russlands
Gefängnisse und illegale annektionen
nicht sehen ich bin hier damit sie die
Dinge klar sehen wie sehr auch immer
russland versucht hier zu beeinflussen
wenige Stunden vorselinskys Auftritt
feierte ein mutmaßlicher
Kriegsverbrecher sein Comeback nur in
Russland und Iran war syriens Machthaber
Baschar al Assad bislang willkommen
aber der saudische Kronprinz bin Salman
will neue Wege gehen ein Experiment so
heißt es in jeder
wir müssen ein neues Kapitel aufschlagen
und diese schmerzvollen Jahre der
Konflikte zurücklässen in denen die
Menschen litten und die Entwicklung der
Region stockte die Rückkehr Assets sei
ihren Bedingungen geknüpft wenn er
Flüchtlinge reintegriere könne er auf
arabische Investitionen hoffen
für Kronprinz Mohammed bin Salman ist
der Gipfel eine Bühne um seine globalen
Ambitionen zu zeigen während die USA an
Einfluss verlieren ergreifen die
golfländer einmütig wie nie die
Initiative zum Wohle der eigenen
wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung
was ist zu erwarten von diesen neuen
Wegen der Golf Länder
nun der saudische Kronprinz drückte
seine Erwartungshaltung so aus er sagte
er hoffe dass Syrien den Weg zur
Normalität zurückfindet und seine Zitat
normale Rolle in der arabischen Heimat
wieder einnimmt so dass die gesamte
Region davon profitieren können das
klingt ein bisschen so als
obsaudi-arabien versucht besser als
heute wieder in seinen Orbit
zurückzuholen
wegzureißen vom russischen Einfluss vom
iranischen Einfluss aber die
saudi-schäden offenbar keine Illusionen
darüber sie wissen dass das ein langer
beschwerlicher Weg ist und dass der
Teufel im Detail steckt denn die Frage
ist Dr scharf hat sich darauf einlassen
wird die saudischen Bedingungen zu
erfüllen ob er der Richtige ist für eine
nationale Versöhnung syrische
Flüchtlinge haben jedes Recht dies zu
bezweifeln ihre Erfahrungen zeigen immer
wieder dass Rückkehrer in syrischen
Gefängnissen gelandet sind oder aber
verschwanden die Frage ist ob du jemand
wie Assad der richtige ist der geeignete
ist
jemand der so viele Probleme bereitet
hat diese Probleme auch zu lösen oder
aber ob mit seiner Normalisierung nicht
noch viel größere Probleme entstehen
im Iran sind drei weitere Menschen
hingerichtet worden wegen der Teilnahme
an Protesten gegen das Regime
beschuldigt wurden die Männer während
der landesweiten Demonstrationen im
vergangenen Herbst drei
Sicherheitskräfte getötet zu haben ihre
Geständnisse sagt Amnesty International
sein unter Folter erzwungen worden Jörg
Brase berichtet
ich bin die Mutter von sajet Jacobi ich
bitte euch helft unseren Kindern sie
sind zum Tode verurteilt heute durften
wir Sie das letzte Mal besuchen
doch alles Flehen vor zwei Tagen nutzte
nichts mehr in der Nacht auf Freitag
wurden Salemi Majid kasemie Jakobi
hingerichtet Proteste vor dem Gefängnis
in Istan hatte die Polizei mit Tränengas
aufgelöst es musste schnell gehen das
hatte Irans justiz-chef öffentlich
gefordert
Polizisten starben den Märtyrer tot
andere wurden verletzt wir müssen sie
unterstützen die Verfahren zu ihren
Fällen müssen zu einem schnellen Ende
gebracht werden
bei den landesweiten Protesten waren im
November in Isfahan diese drei
Polizisten und Mitglieder
paramilitärischer basismilizen getötet
worden die Verhaftung der
Tatverdächtigen wird medienwirksam
inszeniert als diese Bilder entstehen
sind Majid kasemis Hände bereits auf den
Rücken gefesselt es folgen Videos mit
Geständnissen wie immer in solchen
Fällen in Audioaufnahmen die im
Gefängnis entstanden beteuern die drei
Angeklagten immer wieder ihre Unschuld
die Männer die mich verhaftet haben
haben mich gefoltert ich hatte keine
Waffen oder ähnliche ich hatte gar
nichts sie haben mich immer weiter
geschlagen und behauptet diese Waffen
wären meine ich sagte okay die Waffen
sind meine
bis heute wurden mindestens sieben
Menschen im Zusammenhang mit dem
Protesten hingerichtet Irans Führung
nimmt Rache und wie der Erfolg weiter
einschüchtern
in die Slowakei vor mehr als fünf Jahren
wurde der junge investigativ Journalist
Jack und seine Verlobte ermordet heute
gab es in dem Mordprozess das Urteil das
viele irritiert der Geschäftsmann Marian
kotschner wurde erneut freigesprochen
seine angebliche Komplizin Alena muss
dagegen 25 Jahre hinter Gitter jan
kutziak hatte in der Slowakei ein
kriminelles Geflecht aus Mafia und
Firmen enthüllt das bis in die Spitzen
der Politik reicht
nach Deutschland der Weg zum deutschen
Pass soll einfacher werden zumindest für
Ausländer die hier eine Arbeit haben und
gut integriert sind so steht es in einem
Gesetzentwurf den das Innenministerium
heute veröffentlicht hat danach soll die
Einbürgerung bereits nach fünf statt
acht Jahren möglich sein es gibt aber
Bedingungen Christian Volk hat Details
ein großer Moment für Sophia aus der
Ukraine für Nelly und Aldo aus Mexiko
und für Eiern aus Syrien sie bekommen
vor wenigen Wochen in Hamburg ihre
Einbürgerungsurkunde solche Verfahren
will die Regierung künftig beschleunigen
außerdem sollen Migrantinnen und
Migranten ihre ursprüngliche
Nationalität behalten dürfen das war
bisher nur in Ausnahmefällen möglich wir
vollziehen den lange überfälligen
Paradigmenwechsel und lassen die
mehrstatigkeit zu sogleich ermöglichen
wir die Einbürgerung schon nach fünf
statt nach acht Jahren wer besonders gut
integriert ist kann diesen Zeitraum auf
drei Jahre verkürzen
Voraussetzungen sind Sprachkenntnisse
ein Einbürgerungstest und ein eigenes
Einkommen auch in Deutschland geborene
Kinder ausländische Eltern sollen
schneller deutsche werden können
wir schaffen ein modernes
Einwanderungsrecht mit zwei klaren
Botschaften wer hier mit uns lebt
arbeitet und von dieser Arbeit leben
kann der kann schneller deutscher
Staatsbürger werden das ist in unserem
Interesse umgekehrt wer vom Sozialstaat
lebt kann nicht eingebürgert werden denn
wir haben Interesse an Zuwanderung in
den Arbeitsmarkt aber nicht in den
Sozialstaat auch Straftaten aus
antisemitischen rassistischen oder
fremdenfeindlichen Motiven sollen eine
Einbürgerung unmöglich machen die Union
kritisiert die Pläne als falsches Signal
sie fürchtet eine Entwertung der
deutschen Staatsangehörigkeit der
Gesetzentwurf geht nun in die Abstimmung
mit den Ländern und Verbänden bis zum
Sommer soll ihn das Kabinett
verabschieden
beim heizungsgesetz bleibt die Ampel
uneins SPD und Grüne halten am Zeitplan
fest das Gesetz bis zur Sommerpause zu
verabschieden die FDP Tritt auf die
Bremse es gebe noch 100 Fragen an
Minister Habeck dessen
Wirtschaftsministerium signalisierte
jetzt in einigen Punkten offen für
Veränderungen zu sein beispielsweise
soll eine Kombination von Öl oder
Heizkesseln mit Wärmepumpen dauerhaft
zugelassen werden
der deutsche Aktienindex lag noch nie so
hoch wie heute mit über
16.330 Punkten ließ er seine bisherige
Bestmarke klar hinter sich die stammt
von November 2021 und damit aus der Zeit
vor Beginn der russischen Invasion schon
gestern hatte die Aussicht auf eine
Lösung im Schuldenstreit in den USA den
DAX steigen lassen hinzu kommt dass die
Wirtschaft in Europa stärker wächst als
zunächst vorhergesagt
muttermilch ist die beste Nahrung für
Babys für Frühgeborene ist sie sogar
überlebenswichtig weil sie die winzigen
Frühchen vor tödlichen Krankheiten
schützt und zwar egal ob die Milch von
der eigenen Mutter kommt oder von einer
anderen heute am internationalen Tag der
Milch Spende zeigt Thomas Bersch wie
existenziell diese Spenden sind und
warum es so schwer ist genug davon zu
bekommen
wenn Sabine Männchen und ihre
Kolleginnen früh ihre Arbeit in der
Uniklinik Dresden beginnen dann hoffen
sie dass nicht zu viele Frühgeborene auf
ihrer Station dazu kamen denn die
brauchen gespendete Muttermilch und die
ist knapp Frauen die eine Frühgeburt
bekommen haben sind vor allem in den
ersten Tagen häufig noch so wie in einem
Schockzustand und dann kommt die eigene
Muttermilch häufig nicht so im Gang die
Vorräte reichen gerade so durch Corona
vielen und fallen SpenderInnen aus wenn
in der Milch eine Viruslast nachweisbar
ist und die Milch muss ja von den
SpenderInnen irgendwie in die Klinik
kommen und auch hier zeigt sich wie
überall der Personalmangel wir haben
keine Fahrer die gibt's einfach nicht
Personal technisch nicht die in zwei
größere Umfeld fahren können so dass wir
nur die Stadt Dresden im Moment
absichern können weltweit kommen 4 bis
15% der Babys zu früh zur Welt in
Deutschland sind es sechs Prozent 2021
wurden hier 50.000 Kinder vor der 37
Schwangerschafts Woche geboren die
Uniklinik Dresden sucht Händeringen
SpenderInnen wie eine Schlüter z.B ihre
kleine Marke kam acht Wochen zu früh
eine Schlüter sagte gleich im
Krankenhaus zu dass sie auch mich
spenden würde
jetzt ist es halt so dass meine Mutter
mich Produktion so viel ist und da habe
ich durch die Schwestern hier spende ich
jetzt selber und es ist sehr schön auch
was Gutes tun zu können in wenigen Tagen
können Mutter und Kind nach Hause doch
sie wohnen zu weit außerhalb Dresdens
als Spenderin scheidet eine Schlüter
damit also wieder aus
nicht nur in Teilen Südeuropas herrscht
auch dieses Jahr Wasser Notstand eine
Studie zeigt dass dies ein globaler
Trend ist mehr als die Hälfte 53% der
größten Seen weltweit verliert Wasser
ausgewertet wurden für die Studie und
eine viertel Millionen
Satellitenaufnahmen aus fast 30 Jahren
die Hauptgründe für die Austrocknung
sind der Klimawandel und ein übermäßiger
Wasserverbrauch durch den Menschen
und jetzt der Sport Rudi Endspurt in der
Fußball-Bundesliga ist noch einiges
offen heute beginnt der vorletzte
Spieltag der Fokus liegt auf dem
Fernduell zwischen Bayern München und
Borussia Dortmund um die Meisterschaft
spannend bis zum Schluss bleibt auch der
Kampf um die internationalen Plätze und
um den Klassenerhalt haben die Bayern
Untertitel zur alten Souveränität
gefunden hat Dortmund Trainer persisch
seinem Team die Auswärtsschwäche
ausgetrieben Fragen des vorletzten
Spieltags an dem Freiburg schon heute
Abend das Programm eröffnet eine erneute
Pleite gegen Wolfsburg und nichts ist
mit Champions League die Euro liegt als
Trostpreis Freiburgs Kontrahenten folgen
am Samstag Urs Fischer und Union Berlin
bräuchten da nur ein Unentschieden in
Hoffenheim Leipzig könnte sich bei den
Bayern sogar eine Niederlage erlauben
kann das die Meisterschaft beeinflussen
die Bayern zuletzt klarer Sieger gegen
Schalke gegen den Titel Rennen in den
Vorlage am Sonntag erst lieber alle
Dortmund in Augsburg eine Niederlage bei
einem Bayern Sieg und der BVB wurde den
Bayern den 11 Titel in Folge auf dem so
FA servieren überhaupt gar kein Problem
damit wie das passiert
ist fast schon der Abstieg von Hertha
BSC gegen Bochum muss ein Sieg her sonst
wäre Trainer dabei seinen Ruf als
retterlos
apropos aus der Traum vom Europa liegt
Triumph für Bayer Leverkusen im
Halbfinale Rückspiel verpasste das Team
den Einzug ins Finale durch ein 0:0
gegen die extrem defensiv eingestelltem
Mannschaft von AS Rom nach dem 0:1 im
Hinspiel fand die Jagd nach dem dritten
Titel in der Vereinsgeschichte damit ein
vorzeitiges Ende die Konzentration für
die Mannschaft von chabi Alonso liegt
jetzt auf der bundesliga-schlussphase
und die deutsche Eishockey
Nationalmannschaft hat mit dem ersten
Sieg bei der WM in Finnland und Lettland
den Einzug ins Viertelfinale gewahrt die
Auswahl von Bundestrainer Harald Kreis
gewann gegen Dänemark mit sechs zu vier
und Siegtreffer erzielte Nico Sturm in
der Schlussminute nach drei Niederlagen
gegen Schweden Finnland und die USA muss
Deutschland heute zunächst gegen
Österreich nachlegen um sich fürs
Viertelfinale noch qualifizieren zu
können
jo ich habe es
danke schön zum Schluss hätten wir noch
Neues aus der Wirtschaft zum will aus
der Wissenschaft zum Thema küssen wobei
Forscher aus Oxford und Kopenhagen nicht
dieser saute Kuss nachgegangen sind oder
dieser sondern dem Kuss in eindeutig
erotische Absicht den gibt es quer durch
viele Kulturen seit mindestens
3.800 Jahren sagen die Experten und
verweisen unter anderem auf diese nicht
ganz jugendfreie lehntafel aus
Mesopotamien bislang galt der feurige
Kuss als 300 Jahre jünger
das wissen sie auch das das Wochenende
wird wärmer zugleich steigt leider die
Gewittergefahr die Details hat gleich
Christa auch wenn das heute journal um
10 mit Christian Sievers wir wünschen
Ihnen ein schönes Wochenende bis morgen
wenn Sie mögen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
ja guten Abend tiefer Druck über dem
Mittelmeer sorgt für weiteren Regen in
Italien und auch in Korsika und
Sardinien wir schauen zum Wetter bei uns
und bringt jetzt eine östliche Strömung
am Rande dieses hochdruckgebietes etwas
mildere und feuchtere Luft und diese
Warmluftzufuhr sorgt dafür dass ich
heute Nacht Wolken nordwestwärts
ausbreiten da kann es auch mal draus
tröpfeln wo es aufklärt sinken die
Temperaturen auf 5 Grad aber Frost ist
kein Thema mehr im Rhein-Main-Gebiet
bleibt es bei 11 Grad morgen ist das
etwas milder als heute frühlingshafte 16
Grad im hessischen Bergland und 23 Grad
in den südöstlichen Landesteilen werden
gemessen an den Küsten ist es mit 15 16
Grad etwas kühler und besonders hier
spürt man auch den böhig auffrischende
nordöstlichen Wind dazu gibt's viele
Wolken gelegentlich mal Sonne am meisten
sieht man die im Nordwesten und im
Südosten dazu sind vormittags im
östlichen Bergland und auch an den Alpen
erste Schauer möglich nachmittags gibt
es auch einzelne Gewitter mit Starkregen
und die Gewitter und Unwetter Gefahren
nimmt bis Montag zu dann kommt auch
diese frühsommerliche Luftmasse mit
Temperaturen bis 29 Grad tschüss